this is your first time doing a series
like this
and i'm curious what it was about the
material that said i want to spend
possibly the next four to seven years of
my life making this
you just said four to seven years and
almost fell out of my chair
um
no it what it was was you know we're
huge yellowstone fans and a big taylor
sheridan fan and you know wind river
sicario
hell or high water all the stuff that
he's written
but we were yellowstone fans from the
very first night of the very first
episode and
when all this came around and taylor
started sending scripts to us it
literally was the most beautiful
thing i've i've ever read i mean the
scripts are just so fantastic it just
jumps off the page at you and makes
everything to come to life
when you read it
you picture the entire show and the way
he describes everything and the way he
describes every scene
it's literally a road map for the dp
it's a road map for the set designers
it's a road map for everybody that's
involved
it's all there and all you have to do is
read the script and and you're inspired
by it and that's that's literally what
did it i mean
i wasn't looking for a series to do i
mean gosh i mean i got plenty of other
things to do i mean i wasn't even
looking for a movie to do and um
but but as an artist everything's driven
by the material that's put in front of
you and when when this kind of material
is putting in put in front of you and
it's a challenge and it's something that
you really
are moved by it's it's hard to say no to
i one of the things about this series is
that it's not a soundstage series this
is you guys really on location making it
and i can only imagine the challenges
for not only the cast but the crew in
trying to bring this to life can you
sort of talk about um just the behind
the scenes of the making of the series
and how what how tough it must be yeah
well the crew in particular
i mean they certainly have it a lot
tougher than than the actors do i mean
they the stuff that they have to move
and the elements that they have to move
it in when you even switching locations
within an hour in montana with 30 mile
an hour winds and you know 15 degree
temperatures i mean it's just almost an
impossible task and the wranglers
because we have
you know a herd of cattle we have
you know 50 horses you know all that
stuff that's involved in moving a set
there it's remarkable to me to me to
watch those guys work and i have nothing
but respect for all of them um but yeah
the elements are the toughest part i
mean we
knock on wood we've been fairly lucky i
mean we've we've been burning up when it
was early on and we've been freezing
cold and we've had a few days we had a
few decent days but most of the time
it's either been freezing cold or
burning hot then a couple days it was
both so it's just it's it's been a
challenge but
i think all of that i mean the elements
the the
the scenery
all of that is is a huge character in
this movie as well so i it adds to the
the the
authenticity of it i think
what are you uh my last question for you
um what are you most excited for people
to actually see in the series because i
think taylor just does such a tailor
does such a great job at making you
realize how rough and tough that time
period was
yeah i think for what we did with this
show is really tried to take the veneer
off of of the and the romanticism out of
of how how tough it was because you know
it's easy to watch westerns to think oh
i'd love to live during that time and
then when you see
see how tough it was you're like man
maybe i wouldn't but um
yeah i but for me i think that
honestly speaking and this is coming
from
my other life honestly speaking i can't
wait for people to see my wife and her
performance
in this show i think that she just
knocks it out of the park and
we have always known in our family that
she's the steel and the backbone of our
family and without her our universe will
just fall apart
but i think she's carried that over into
margaret's character and you see that in
margaret's character that she she's
she's the rock that holds everybody in
place yeah i think the two of you
together are also real good
i just want to say congrats i know the
show is going to be a big hit thank you
for giving me your time my pleasure
thank you